[Music]
for a libertarian do you do think Trump
has been a disaster because I can see
arguments that make some sense
libertarian wise in terms of some of the
state stuff and some of taxes stuff that
kind of makes sense on a traditional
libertarian or even conservative side
and then some of the bigger government
things that don't make sense
I think Jeff session is the worst
presidential appointment of my lifetime
Wow he's a disaster and that alone the
sort of those states rights no fourth
amendment Jeff Sessions is terrible uh I
have some friends including Walter block
at Loyola University in New Orleans who
is hoping that Trump will be something
good on foreign policy I think you can
make that argument I don't think that I
think Trump's inability even to consider
rule of law and the constitutional
restrictions on the presidency it make
even worse the slide that we've been in
for an expansion of an imperial
presidency so I worry that all of those
bonds are now going to be broken and
we're going to look for the big man the
Messiah and we're just going to trade
back and forth between different visions
of that and that can never work yeah and
that goes exactly to where we started
this conversation about looking for that
Messiah do you think that our
institutions are actually strong enough
I mean I'm a believer that these
institutions still have enough power
that if Trump was to do something truly
illegal or truly overstepping executive
authority that even though the
Republicans control Congress that there
that we still have enough juice left in
the system to take care of that so that
I think would sort of mitigate some of
my fears about him for sure absolutely
the system is pretty strong in a way so
James Madison in Federalist 51 said that
the structure of the government should
be such that addition is made to
counteract ambition so you can be a
Republican member of the Senate but you
look in the mirror you see a god man I
am a badass right I have the power of
the Senate here the president is trying
to use executive orders I don't like
that much because it makes me less
powerful as a senator and so a number of
people in the Senate I think we'll use
Madison's ambition must be made to
counteract ambition incite to limit
Trump at some point yeah so as a guy
that I can tell obviously you're not a
big Trump fan but you still trust in the
system what do you make of when you hear
someone like Maxine Waters constantly
saying we're going to figure out a way
to impeach him you know like we don't
know what it is yet but we're going to
get there that to me that is almost more
undermining of the system than the
excesses that trump may or may not have
or may or may not be doing at the moment
I agree with everything you said except
almost oh it is more undermining of the
system so we don't have a parliamentary
system where a vote of no-confidence is
enough
it takes high crimes and misdemeanors
and I was actually proud of the American
system in 1998 where for no good reason
Bill Clinton there's a lot of problems
with Bill Clinton but he was impeached
in the Senate of this is stupid
well I think that that would happen
again there's the Democrats were very
upset when there was a movement among
Republicans to say we should impeach
Barack Obama mm-hmm so I think that this
may just be background and the the nice
way to interpret it is it's a way for
Democrats to raise money from their base
they don't actually mean it but it just
you read me doubt they're little yeah
right which is also pretty horrible okay
but yes saying it yeah means that you're
undermining the rule of law you're
actually doing what you say you're upset
at Trump for doing yeah so is there any
way in politics right now that you look
at you go these guys basically on board
with with the principles that I believe
in it won't surprise you to learn that I
admire Rand Paul no and I actually like
to Gary Johnson I thought really well
let's talk about him for a little bit
blur let's just talk about him within
the framework of libertarian politics
I've had him on the show I spent time
with him about a half hour before we
were on air I think he's a totally
lovely guy really and I enjoy talking to
him and I can
see us being friends actually but the
candidacy was pretty terrible it was the
greatest ever it was three times as much
as we've ever gotten before we got three
percent that's amazing that was enough
for ballot access in many states but do
you think that might have just been a
function of discussed with the other two
that sorry that Gary himself that
unfortunate he just seemed ill-equipped
to be up there and have enough of a
command of the issues well by the way I
say that with total sympathy for him
because there was nothing he could do to
get in the news except flub they would
only talk about it when he flub so he
was in an unwinnable decision he is so
much better than anything else that we
have had and I mean I'm actually a
libertarian partisan I ran for governor
of North Carolina in 2008 I did not win
yeah uh we're gonna get to that well I I
campaigned with Gary Johnson I got I got
to know him pretty well
yes he flopped the he was tired he made
a bunch of mistakes and that's what the
media emphasized it was really important
that he got three percent and in fact if
you were to look suppose you stripped
away the party labels and your visitor
from Mars yeah well there's this person
who has been a secretary of state and
has experience as a senator and then
there's these two people who were multi
term governors of pretty mixed States
and then some psycho person in realistic
you don't think alright those are the
libertarian candidate so I my question
would be compared to what I thought Gary
Johnson did a great job yeah he does he
did the the best of libertarian
candidate has ever done he gave us
something to build on did I cringe at
the Aleppo incident of course yeah well
that's the thing I but in August I I
endorsed him basically with the idea of
let's get the guy to fifteen percent so
that at least for one debate because we
know the Democrats and Republicans
control the debates at least for one
debate because they'd never let him in a
second one but at least for one let's
hear some of these limited government
ideas and unfortunately there just
wasn't enough juice there but you know
what I'm hearing you and maybe I will
ease off a little of course there's
compared to what yeah you got three
percent the best we ever did was one
percent all right so then what does that
mean to you is the is the future for the
Libertarian Party and do you think that
third party actually cat if that 3%
means something to you do you think that
that means it could be six percent in
2020 could it could it be really
impactful in 2020 third parties in a
system of first-past-the-post which is
what we have you're always going to have
two main parties in a
first-past-the-post system but the
positions of the parties will depend
partly on the pressure that's bought
brought to bear and if you have someone
you can participate in debates
particularly at the state level you can
remind the two state sponsored parties
of the things that are in their platform
that they're leaving out so I don't
think a third party is going to win but
what I care about is the policies not
the face and remember I care about rules
and not the people yeah so if the two
state sponsored parties are obliged by
opening up to the the scolding winds of
competition and they have better
policies that that's what I hope that
the third parties can do yeah I hear
people on the right all the time say
well if we back a libertarian what you
end up doing is splitting the vote on
the right and then you help people on
the Left how would you explain to
somebody that that may not matter and
maybe that has to happen well you only
get one vote and sometimes people do
advocate what political scientists call
voting the lote lesser of two evils if
you vote for the lesser of two evils
you're certainly going to get an evil
right the only way to waste your vote is
to vote for a candidate you don't
actually want and if you vote for a
candidate that you do want that's going
to give a signal to the two
state-sponsored parties that we don't
find this to be acceptable so but all
your votes are wasted they don't
determine the outcome now what I get
then is conservatives particularly
saying what if everyone thought that way
ah
Jetta you are your vote affects
thousands of others No right you have
one vote you can choose to waste it or
you can vote what you actually believe
and try to send a signal yeah which I
think would be more important than just
throwing it away well I say to evil I
would think that there the I think we've
gotten stuck in this lesser of two evils
as the two parties have gotten more and
more evil yeah do you think part of that
also is that the whole system now when I
say the system I mean our political
system and our media system there's only
a certain type of person who would run
but and now we can talk a little bit
also about your 2008 campaign but that
it would take you know the idea of
having to deal with what your family
will have to deal with they're going to
track down every email that you ever had
every if I get an affair or whatever it
is just all that method you're only
going to get a certain type of person
that wants to do this and but my
basically good decent people will self
select out I hear this all the time
every time I see somebody or I talk to
somebody that I think should be in
politics that wouldn't want to subject
myself to that but many guests fear that
privately I said you want to run for
something and everyone no never
there's really two problems one is the
process of running is very difficult
takes a lot of time and you constantly
have your motives questioned and it's
psychologically very difficult the other
problem is if you win you have to serve
and a lot of people that are really good
at things are really good at things
they're doing something else so you have
to be the sort of person who that I
don't want to say too much about Donald
Trump but who just thinks of yourself as
being essentially invaluable and the
problem is we as voters validate that so
I found often in debates and talking to
people voters would ask a question about
some policy now actually that's actually
really complicated that's something
experts disagree about here are the two
arguments you can see their eyes glazing
over and my opponents would say I know
exactly the right thing to do and here
it is and then they would say something
stupid but that wins i win I know what
to do is always going to win over this
is hard yeah which is also a great
argument for small government to admit
it every now and I don't know what to do
so maybe we shouldn't be you know
passing just things that are going to
completely change efficient because the
truth is nobody knows what comes out on
the other side and the fact that
something is a problem doesn't mean that
there's a solution so the I I call that
the we should do something problem X is
a problem okay we should do something Y
is something
therefore we should do why it doesn't
follow the fact that something should be
done but then they'll say well you don't
care about X so unemployment and poverty
are problems and so there are these
things that we should do right and I
said what those things won't work oh you
hate work yeah and it's almost
impossible to to extricate yourself out
of that right sorry so you ran as
libertarian candidate for governor of
North Carolina in 2008 so first off
within since here I can tell you're a
real politic person why not just run as
a Republican which would have perhaps
giving you a better shot just just start
just living the reality of I live in
North Carolina yeah
our Democrats are Republicans our
Republicans are Taliban they're there
they want Sharia law now it's Christian
Sharia right right so they're vets so
this is the real Christian right I would
have come in eighth in a seven-person
primary if I had run as a Republican
uh-huh so there there really is no
constituency in North Carolina among the
Republicans for my view of conservatism
but if the Democrats or Republicans why
not run as a Democrat in the I
considered running as a Democrat but the
Democrats have had a machine that
controlled the state and it was clear
who the nominee was going to be I also
might the reason that I ran was my
objection to North Carolina's ballot
access laws we have some of the most
restrictive ballot access laws in the
country if Coke and Pepsi could decide
on many soft drinks there should be they
would say to the Republicans and
Democrats actually get to do that and
they think 2 is the right number yeah so
all I did we had to raise about $300,000
to get on the ballot and then we could
never get enough votes to stay on the
ballot so eight times we've spent all
this money all this collection of
signatures yeah I figured that I could
get 2% it takes 2% to stay on the ballot
we've never done that so if you set your
goals really low you could be a success
I got more than 2% so I figured I could
do that and I did that was my objective
yeah I get the 2% I got 2.8 percent do
you think that some of those ideas that
you are running
and in 2008 have taken root in North
Carolina they were at least mentioned by
the other candidates and sometimes the
newspapers would even point this out
also I was in for televised debates and
in some ways I'm their worst nightmare
I have a PhD in economics I'm a certain
superficial glibness and I'm not winning
so I could answer the questions yeah I
haven't got the superficial bliss maybe
it'll come or maybe you're very
effective at it and I thank you what do
you think is the reason that the
libertarians haven't done more at the
state level when people talk about the
libertarians they go whoa Carrie Johnson
or whatever is right and and yes there
is rampaul but technically he's a
Republican absolutely there's Justin
Amash there's a couple people but why
haven't they done more just on the local
level this seems like a major opening
for them coming over here I was
promising myself I wasn't going to
answer this question but what the heck
go crazy I'll say here's what happens at
libertarian meetings the first one
twenty or thirty people show up and
they're all enthusiastic yeah and at the
second meeting ten people show up and
the ten say I'm really glad those others
didn't come back they weren't real
libertarians because what they're mainly
concerned about is checking each other's
papers so you can tell if it's a real
libertarian meeting by how long is it
before there's an argument about whether
individuals should be able to own
nuclear weapons yeah nobody cares about
that when I was running for governor
people would say would you end the Fed
yeah I'm running for governor exactly
this end is that yeah but I want to know
so what we really care about is
ideological purity because if you cared
about actual policy or winning you would
suck it up and be a Democrat a
Republican right so the problem that we
have as libertarians is I don't think
people conceive themselves as being part
of a political process they think of
themselves as Oh Trey as being outside
and truth tellers the keepers of a last
flickering remnant of truth yeah and
that's just not a very effective
political strategy that's interesting
because to me after doing this show for
about two years and having you know a
lot of classical liberals on a lot of
libertarians and I've had progressives
conservatives and everything that to me
basically the difference that I see
between classical liberals and
libertarians is a little more realistic
utility for the state so when someone
comes into with that question and says
to you what are you going to get rid of
the Fed you've got money for governor
and also that's a really high-level
philosophical thing that we you know
that to me it's just it's just a more
realistic approach to how to change
things do you think that's a fair
assessment yes and I've made a
distinction in a couple of things that
I've written between directional and
destination of libertarians destination
this libertarians have a particularly
Bert Opia in mind at anything that's not
like that is out directional ists would
want to say are there policies that we
could choose that would be cheaper lower
deficits lower the power of the state
and increase personal responsibility and
liberty so an example would be when I
was running for governor what my
educational platform was vouchers and a
lot of people means-tested vouchers so
the poorest 40% would get more school
choice many of the wealthy have it now
let's have more school choice for the
very poor and a lot of people on the
Left were kind of interested in that
there's a lot of african-american
citizens that are just desperate to get
their school their children into better
schools and libertarians almost about
exceptions that oh no the state would be
involved in that the only acceptable
libertarian policy is the immediate
elimination of all taxes right again
this is the part that is not the
realistic part because their destination
us
yeah so the the destination estar always
going to be there the what libertarians
are they're going to have any success
are going to have to appeal to the
directional list in both parties let's
say look the government has too many
powers we may disagree about how far
back we want to move it but let's move
the Train in the other direction we're
going the wrong way
I think there's a consensus we should
move it back where we get off the train
that's a different question yeah but
let's change the direction what would
you say is the easiest way to explain
state power when I mean state I mean
local or federal to the person that
doesn't quite get this to the person
that when you talk about government
power and government overreach that they
don't think it's like you're talking
about some sort of ephemeral thing that
doesn't really do we think the best
to get them to start understanding the
ideas of why what Liberty really is well
this is obviously something I've thought
about a lot and I haven't really
succeeded so you're asking what the best
argument it is but it's very frustrating
because people have a conception of a
thing called a state so something I've
written a lot about is the unicorn
conception of the state so imagine that
I have a mass transit proposal and what
we'll have is these large carts that are
pulled by unicorns and unicorns are
great for mass transit because they eat
rainbows they're very strong and they're
flatulence smells like fresh
strawberries so there's no emission
you'd not know that fight it's what
there's no emissions problem that got
really great now you could object well I
think there's a problem with this
actually because unicorns don't really
exist close your eyes you see one yeah
so do I they totally exist in the sense
that I can imagine them that's how
people think of the state when I say
here's look the state is messing up well
right because we have bad people
all we need to do is get the right debt
battery because I can imagine a state
that's doing these things it's very
difficult to fight that so the argument
that I try to make haven't given that
caveat yeah it's hard to fight unicorns
because that's what people want is
something they can imagine not something
that exists but the argument that I
actually try to make is that every flaw
in consumers and there are many is worse
in voters
so you think consumers are too stupid to
be able to choose what size Coke to buy
or which car to buy voters have all
those problems and more so my colleague
Dan Ariely at Duke who writes about
rationality and consumer problems and
once the state to intervene there's no
such thing as the state there's just
people if we're going to have voters
choose what these experts are going to
make people do it'll be even worse than
the market right so it's like so
basically we are the flaw in the system
in a really perverse way that the best
system is one that recognizes that and
doesn't try to do too much because if we
give voters enough power they'll do what
they did in the south
and afflicts minorities though though or
they'll say no same-sex marriage there's
no reason to think that if you take one
person who's too stupid to make his own
choices at the grocery store and put
them together in it with an angry mama
right they can then choose a good
president or a good food and drug
administration
[Music]
you